hi I'm Joyce Sunday and I play Bianca
Barclay hi I'm Emma Meyers and I play
Enid Sinclair hey I'm Hunter durian I
play Tyler Galpin hello my name is Jenna
Ortega and I'm Wednesday I'm Percy Hines
white and I'm Xavier we are the cast of
Wednesday and we are going to take the
BuzzFeed quiz that's not the line
um
we are the cast of Wednesday and we're
here with BuzzFeed no I got it I got it
I'm sorry I'm just I feel the pressure
we are the cast of Wednesday and we are
here with BuzzFeed to decipher which
Adam's Family character we are
foreign
which word from The Addams Family theme
song best describes you creepy kooky
mysterious spooky altogether ookie none
of these
all together I'm gonna pin you as an all
together ookie person I think you're
mysterious thank you
I want someone to pick creepy I
I did what did you pick all together
choose something spooky and fun to watch
for your next movie night Hocus Pocus
Casper Beetlejuice The Nightmare Before
Christmas Corpse Bride or it yeah I
think beetlejuices
oh go in the Nam Tim Burton Realm
I picked Beetlejuice I
love Beetlejuice that's my girl what's
your ideal Halloween costume ghost
zombie skeleton witch a funny pop
culture reference
or a homicidal maniac AKA no costume
because they look like just like
everybody else
pop culture reference or zombie kind of
Pop Culture reference
you weren't here sucks to suck I'm
curious favorite Halloween costume ever
was being roadkill you get hit by a car
yeah
I was on the side of the New Jersey what
did you choose four hours before someone
found it
uh I chose a funny pop culture reference
which one answers with me
if you chose it I didn't come anywhere
near that what's your funny pop culture
reference go
right now yeah
oh man I should change it pick an Adam's
Family character to trust with the
secret Cousin It Lurch Grandmama or a
thing I'm gonna go with a thing cousin
it because he's a pimp alert because he
doesn't really speak nothing can't
breathe yeah they can't really talk
either yeah I mean thing talks with his
hands
truly grandma is the only one who could
physically tell your secret to somebody
and I felt like she talks a lot so I'm
going Lurch I mean he's driving you all
around if like he overhears a lot and
keeps it I'm gonna go things
are tight choose a quote from The Addams
Family movies
I would die for her I would kill for her
either way what Bliss no excuse aim for
a major artery the jugular thing you're
a handful you severely underestimate my
apathy salt pepper or cyanide I'm just
like any Modern Woman trying to have it
all loving husband a family it's just I
wish I had more time to seek out the
dark Forces and join their hellish
Crusade I'm gonna go with the last one
dude Joey Cusack man she's incredible I
wish it was the greatest monologue of
all time I know I wish it was the don't
I deserve love and Jewelry
I'm gonna go to salt pepper side there's
a part of me that just wants to go with
no excuse and for a major artery the
jugular
finally pick something to add a pop of
color to your wardrobe a bow a hat a
pair of boots a choker a backpack or a
blazer
[Music]
for me I'm gonna get a backpack I'm
gonna get a pair of boots
[Music]
should we go in order this is not order
but I'm Wednesday Adams should we go
together I'll go first
I got Morticia Adams
could that be known Morticia Adams I
also boss I also got more attention I
got Wednesday because I'm not a boss
baby whoa because they said that not
because you're not adopted yeah I'm so
sorry
[Music]
I cannot believe that responds should be
ashamed I should be ashamed can I take
it again you're wins Adams like
Wednesday you have a dark personality
and you gravitate towards the gruesome I
mean sometimes others don't fully
appreciate you for who you are but the
good news is you truly could not care
less you are an icon and besides you've
got more important things to do like
playing with your brother your Morticia
Adams like The Adams Family matriarchy
you're incredibly glamorous and a style
icon for the spooky you're deeply loyal
and loving to your family and you always
uphold Adam's family values and through
your shared Love of All Things Macabre
you've found a true perfect partnership
proving you're also a real romantic I
really wanted to be faster dude
make sure to watch Wednesday on Netflix
[Music]
thank you